it's not too dark it's not too dark
because I've always just got on with it
you can't stop as we say stopping is a
luxury
like when you're when you're under
pressure
you put a lot of expectation on yourself
you just gotta keep on going you've got
to keep on going so I don't have time to
stop but in those quiet times
when I when I'm sitting there and I'm
questioning myself which is
self-accountability
I am I definitely had to like Soul
search a bit you know Soul search
question myself how do I get better what
am I looking for what's the purpose why
did I act like that if it happened again
how could I do better but I didn't look
for answers from anyone else except for
myself and that's
that in a way was good because even
though I was asking how I'm going to
deal with these things is preparing me
for the future which means that I must
want to continue
and these are the questions I was
figuring out yeah I do want to continue
did you question
my position in this world I don't need
boxing to make me feel special at all I
could be done with boxing today I'll
still be the same oh gee same person
like I never use boxing to boost my ego
you talked about your new coach you've
got a new setup
yeah what what I did
so in terms of adding we've actually
subtracted
um okay yeah toned it down a bit
normally when I'm in London I could
train I'm full of life and full of
energy I'll train go do a commercial
come back I'm asking boys I'm on the
phone in the morning handling business
before I go training like I'm on it but
being out of that environment I
sacrificed I said I'm not interested in
any business I'm just fully focused on
on boxing so I got rid of all the noise
I subtracted and this fight
win fight for you is that how you view
it yeah
every fight is but I feel like
everyone's always watching me so yeah
this is a Muslim fight and then funnily
enough the next fight after this I'll be
getting asked the same question so it's
always going to be that way always
a lot of pressure there's always a lot
of pressure yeah but are you looking
forward to the fight or is it just
something to get through
a bit of a mix
it's a bit of a mix because
the get through element is you know how
tough It's going to be
but they're looking forward to it is
I've been here I belong here
like you can't step into the lines then
and have any doubt in your mind it's
there'll be too too risky too risky any
form of Doubt is where you get found out
so I just gotta be relentless and look
forward to the job and what's crazy I
always think of it this way is like
it'll be Sunday morning and I'll be
having breakfast
and I'll be like oh it's done do you
think you can see yourself in your mind
as world champion again
it's a great question thanks very much
that's a great question because
I could say
I don't want people to hold me to this
answer because that's what it's like but
I'm someone that's practical and
realistic is is far away
is very far away and I'm quite like one
one step one day at a time
I can
but let me get through these hurdles
first the fact that everybody wants to
see is Tyson Fury and you do you think
that fight will ever happen before
you're both 40. well I'll be honest I'll
be honest that's one of the reasons why
I'm still around in the boxing business
and I'm hanging on
um it's a tough old game it's a tough
old game like as I said the questions
I've asked myself and one of them was I
need to do it for the British public I
think that they've demanded it from me
and as much as
um this is about me
the British public and out of public
have helped build this Empire that I've
got so I owe it to them so from my
perspective I'd love to get that fight
cracking not just for me but for the
people that deserve it